this came from a book Brian Selznick
whose name you saw up there how did you
find out about his work and his
screenplay that made you say AHA this is
a property for me the I read the script
before the book and it was actually due
to the fact that Sandy Powell my costume
designer I've worked with many years on
several films worked with Brian worked
on the film Hugo the Scorsese film which
was based on Brian's novel The Invention
of Hugo Cabret and they got to be very
close friends and she read she was
visiting Brian and she read his book
wonderstruck and she said I could see
this being something Todd could do an
illustrator as well he yeah his books
used drawings and text and in the case
of wonderstruck the entire 1927 story
that was depicted like a silent film in
the in our movie is told in drawings and
the seventies story is told in text and
they interweave throughout the course of
the book so it's a very lovely concept
for a young adult novel using image and
text so Brian I don't think it was the
first person that came to Brian's mind
this is the first adaptation up from one
of his books that he himself wrote
because he just didn't think of me as
somebody who made films for a younger
audience so I read the the script first
and it really was beautifully it was
starting to really think of how this
should be a movie and how it could use
film language and how could really
embrace cinema because it's a bit so not
based on dialogue because the two kids
are deaf or big one of them becomes deaf
during the course of the film so it
really needed the visual language of
film to make it work how did you get New
York to bend to your will to be to New
York's none of them the New York of
today I'd say a lot of that was due to
our extraordinary production designer
Mark Friedberg who really had a kind of
vision of like alright we can
that corner in Bushwick and but when we
turn around we're in Crown Heights and
then up the street were back in
Manhattan I mean he really had a vision
that was very specific to two locations
that existed I mean I when I think of
tight you know to me one of the most
extraordinary moments in the movies when
Ben opens the door from Port Authority
and he's in Times Square and I
ilove that moment because it feels I
grew up in New York City and it feels to
me incredibly authentic in a way and I
don't think I've seen a movie do in a in
in a long time and that was really mark
figuring out this corner of that corner
this piece that piece you know in an in
a great way for you Christine for having
New York almost as a character in the
film but a character that plays two
roles to the challenges of as we were
just hearing about getting to use the
museum for example how did you overcome
some of these well you know the museum
was a look the museum was was wonderful
to us and I think they really understood
you know not to talk about that other
Natural History Museum movie but they
sort of understood how this movie was
almost true to their bones and true to
their to their you know to their ideals
and exactly in a way that that they
really wanted to support so they really
look they're a museum they are a Macca I
mean the fact that we got those six
nights in there was pretty amazing night
at the museum didn't get sexy and they
could pay a lot more than we could but I
so they were they were incredibly
supportive and and that you know and
also not just in terms of like the space
but allowing like the spaces that you
see where the kids are where Ben and
Jamie are running around behind the
scenes that was really the museum you
know those those long hallways
corridors with filing cabinets etc that
was also still in the highly protected
areas with with temperature control and
precious you know collections within all
of those cabinet trees so we had guards
and there was a lot of red tape to get
through but we managed to do it and they
were they were incredibly helpful but
there was a bureaucracy certainly to
navigate how did you make silence a
positive instead of just an absence of
sound well we just decided to make the
soundtrack from the music to the sound
design a character in the film from the
very beginning began really talking
deeply with Carter Burwell the composer
about the role music would play of
course music played to such a central
role at the height of the silent era in
movies but I also suspected that it was
going to play an important role in the
Ben's story as well and if the Ben's
story music would be could play a more
subjective role because he had only just
become deaf so for him stepping out into
the into the city that we wanted to play
with perspective sound there would be
moments where all of a sudden we're kind
of hearing the world through his ears
the one thing we learned is that there
is no such thing as absolute silence for
deaf people every deaf person perceives
some register of sound some dimension of
sound some frequency and Ben also only
just became deaf so there was even the
idea that there would be memory of sound
or a kind of phantom limb of sound would
be invading his experience you know so I
thought what a great rich opportunity to
try to evoke that and make the viewers
hearing audiences really think about
what hearing means you know and what it
might be like to be without it Christine
have you gotten any feedback from the
deaf community do you know if were they
consulted in the course of this oh yeah
I mean we we've started working with the
deaf community like from day one I mean
obviously first and foremost in finding
notes and Simmons you know our casting
director Laura Rosenthal really you know
she had to figure out all the different
ways
is to figure out to find children to
find little girls that could potentially
play the role and of course that started
out with you know theater groups and but
you know Millicent actually I think you
said earlier she'd done some acting but
not in films she'd really done just a
little acting in school she really I
mean I'd say it's it's school
Shakespeare I think right you know who
hasn't I so gone Baba I so that that
process was just to talk about that a
little bit cuz I think it's interesting
I think I Laura thinks she saw over two
or three hundred girls she they self
taped they didn't all walk through her
office and then she and her team
narrowed it down to about a dozen and
Todd narrowed that down to about five or
six and then to two and we brought those
two to New York it was Millicent and
another girl but it was a really careful
process and anyway we started involving
the deaf community at that point and
also just you know we wanted to make
sure at the risk of you know the the pun
we wanted to make sure they felt heard
and that they felt like this movie the
same way Brian Selznick book was very
respectful to their community and and
sort of inhaled their experiences and
ways that were very meaningful Millicent
had read the book and in her sort of
audition introduction tape she she said
I identify with Rose I really feel like
I know what she went
how lovely which was incredible I think
we were both like you know everybody was
so so the fact that Brian had already
laid down that groundwork we just picked
it up it also describes the film itself
in the two halves describe the history
of death experience in America in that
the 1920s there was a real stigma
attached to being death death and you
were locked away longer locked away
people didn't embracing in with you and
oralism was
Tati would if you were lucky enough to
get an education and all your basically
taught how to speak and how to
assimilate into the speaking world the
the language was not taken seriously it
wasn't until the early 1960s and
articles came out that's hard to talk
about ASL American Sign Language and
sign language in general as a real
language with all the complexities and
grammatical you know integrity of any
spoken language and it sure did a whole
new era of awareness about death
experience and and signing I think most
of us will remember that the 70s was a
time was like oh yeah people are signing
you know you I think I got really into
it when I was like young was a period
everybody's rights were being asserted
exactly once absolutely and the end
Americans with Disabilities Act shortly
followed as legislation but that is also
shown in the movie where it's a little
Latino boy who goes to the public school
system in New York City who actually
knows the alphabet before the little boy
who just lost his hearing from Minnesota
so it shows how the culture had changed
Julianne Moore found a life for herself
and a vocation for herself and a way to
live as a deaf person in by this time in
in our history